[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News at 10 our top story
speeding into a confrontation which
could question her future swella
brothman defiant after being accused of
breaking ministerial rules I got a
speeding ticket I paid the fine I took
the points in my view nothing Untold has
happened thank you
the record migration figures which could
put the brakes on Zoella brothman a
Hardline Home Secretary has hundreds of
thousands arrive
also tonight 16 years after her
disappearance police searching for the
truth about Madeleine McCann prepared to
search a remote reservoir of the Algarve
four murders one man accused the suspect
in the student killings That Shook
America facing the charges in court
we hear the lack of support for the
survivors of Terror from the Manchester
attack to the fight back on London
Bridge
crime on the football pitch the racist
abuse suffered by one of the world's
best players
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening swella bravman
was probably expecting the controversy
to hit later this week when on Thursday
the Home Secretary is likely to face
questions over an unprecedented rise in
migration into the UK the challenge
though has come days earlier with Ms
brothman accused of asking civil
servants to help her handle a speeding
fine she said she'd done nothing wrong
the Prime Minister said he'd spoken to
the government's ethics advisor a civil
service Union said she'd clearly broken
the ministerial code her political
correspondent Rob Powell has this report
caught on camera not for the first time
the Home Secretary arriving at a London
charity this morning found to be
speeding last summer swella bravaman is
accused of asking civil servants to help
arrange a private speed awareness course
I was speeding I regret that I paid the
fine and I took the points but we're
focused now on delivering for the
British people and working for them did
you ask civil servants to put you on a
one-on-one speed increase in relation to
the process I'm focused on delivering
for the British people do my job at home
safely then what I will say is that in
my view I'm confident that nothing
untoward has happened are you going to
resign Home Secretary
trying to focus on the day job it's
ultimately for the prime minister to
decide whether his ethics advisor opens
an investigation into the Home Secretary
that would likely Center on this part of
the government rule book that states
ministers should uphold the political
impartiality of the Civil Service I've
always been clear that where issues like
this were raised they should be dealt
with properly and they should be dealt
with professionally since I've returned
from the G7 I have been receiving
information on the issues raised I have
met with both the independent advisor
and the Home Secretary I've asked for
further information and I'll update the
on the appropriate course of action in
due course at the home office this row
comes at a tense time with new migration
data this week set to show another big
rise the context of this speeding story
is arguably as important as the
allegations so Ella bravman has been
pushing for tougher measures to curb
migration with some suggestions running
into resistance from other members of
the cabinet she's also ruffled feathers
after giving a speech at a right-wing
conference last week that some felt
sounded a little too much like a
leadership pitch
in the Commons labor accusing the prime
minister of being in Hawk to his party
and unable to act the prime minister is
clearly too weak to sort this out well
if the Home Secretary cannot get a grip
or
rule-breaking Behavior how can she get a
grip on anything else Home Secretary
accusing labor of playing politics they
want to talk about
racks
from the fact that they voted against
tougher sentences for pedophiles and
murderers they want us to ignore the
fact that labor MPS would rather
campaign to stop the deportation of
foreign criminals than back arawanda
scheme we welcome you unless you've come
on
often polarizing some allies of the Home
Secretary do claim the speeding story is
an attempt to discredit her over
migration it's now for Richie sunac to
decide how to proceed a minister with
friends and foes making the way forward
particularly fraught Rob Powell Sky News
in Westminster
well the migration figures due later
this week are likely to be far from the
much repeated promise to reduce numbers
to the tens of thousands there appears
to be tension at the top of government
of whether to prioritize making coming
to the UK harder over economic growth
our business and economics correspondent
no one has this assessment of what to
expect
the country may have voted to leave the
European Union but migration to Britain
is on the verge of hitting a record high
over the past year the country has
opened its doors to people from Ukraine
and Hong Kong a smaller number of
migrants have also crossed the channel
on small boats
but it's also businesses that are
bringing people over using the new
skilled Visa route to help plug
crippling staff shortages and since the
beginning of 2021 when the government
introduced its new post-brexit migration
system you can see the number of people
entering Britain on skilled visas has
soared just as businesses started
struggling with post lockdown staff
shortages
and if we dive deeper into the data we
can see it's the healthcare and it
industries that are relying most heavily
on overseas skilled workers
businesses in these sectors are bringing
over nurses care workers Pharmacists and
software Developers
these are Industries with long-standing
labor shortages
and drilling into the occupations we can
see that nurses and care workers
dominate the skilled Visa route but
chefs accountants and management
Consultants are also coming over in
large numbers
the biggest proportional increases are
being recorded in sectors that form the
country's food supply chain Agriculture
and accommodation and Food Services have
recorded enormous leaps in migrants with
Bakers butchers and Farmers all entering
Britain on skilled visas
businesses in the construction sector
are also using the scheme to offset the
loss of European workers who have been
leaving in recent years
and across the workforce these Europeans
are being replaced by workers from other
parts of the world and as you can see
here it's predominantly Indians that are
making up the shortfall with more than a
hundred thousand coming to Britain on
skilled visas over the past few years
they're being joined by a growing number
of workers from Philippines Nigeria and
the US
so this is the changing face of Migrant
Britain and while the government talks
tough on immigration the country's
post-brexit migration policy is actually
more liberal than ever
well our political cross product Joe
Pike is in Downey Street tonight Joe
some embarrassment then for swella
brothman over speeding fines but that
may be dwarfed by being a hard-line Home
Secretary presiding over record
migration Figures it's a very good point
Anna gurpreet touched on one fascinating
Paradox there here is another for you
even though of course those here at
number 10 and in the home office would
rather avoid headlines about record
migration figures later this week they
actually could ironically help dweller
Bravo make the case for tougher measures
to try and bring those numbers down and
she's not had much success in persuading
cabinet colleagues of the advantages of
some of these measures certainly Jeremy
Hunt said not to be a keen on it because
of the importance of some International
workers to some sections of the economy
the health secretary we're told not keen
either because of the importance of
international workers to the NHS
Workforce and also we're told the
education secretary presumably because
of the importance of international
students to the financing of
universities one thing that could damage
I suppose dwellers Australia's case is
this whole speeding row because as a
former Advocate it doesn't necessarily
show her a judgment in a particularly
good light ultimately it's the Judgment
of the Prime Minister Rishi student as
to whether there is an investigation and
he is the judge as to whether a
ministerial code breach has taken place
one thing though we learned from the
Dominic Rob Rao and the final slow
stages of that Anna is that when it
comes to decision making of Richie sunak
is ironically in this case uh far from
speedy
Joe thank you
for nearly three years German police
have suspected that a convicted child
sex offender Christian B was responsible
for The Disappearance of Madeleine
McCann tomorrow a search will begin
requested by them of a reservoir around
30 miles away from where Madeleine went
missing in prior to luge on the Algarve
Skies reports
it's been 16 years of no answers no
closer to finding this little girl
but now a fresh search concentrated on
this remote Reservoir
the Irish dam is just 30 miles from
where Madeleine McCann was taken from
her bed in prior to luge
the main suspect convicted sex offender
Christian B allegedly called this area
his paradise
he is currently serving a sentence for
raping a woman in the region from where
Madeleine went missing he denies any
involvement in The three-year-old's
Disappearance saying he'd been staying
in his camper van that night
the dam has been searched before as part
of a private investigation in 2008. now
Portuguese and German authorities will
spend the next two days scanning the
water and surrounding Woodland
Scotland Yard detectives are also there
some approach with cautious optimism
I think what's significant is that the
search is being led by the German police
the German police
um are are generally cautious by nature
but they've been absolutely adamant that
they have the right person in custody
and and that they know what happened to
Madeline and and that's an unusual
situation so so that makes me hopeful
the case has haunted the world and
decimated the world of her family
earlier this month they marked what
would have been Madeleine's 20th
birthday and reaffirmed their promise to
never give up on finding her Ashner Sky
News
foreign
ER claimed today that the NHS wouldn't
survive another five years under the
conservatives as he set out an ambitious
but Ambiguously costed planned to
improve it there would be new targets
for ambulance response times cancer
diagnosis and thousands of new staff our
political correspondent Liz Bates
reports
it was all smiles and confidence today
after Labor stepped up its game at the
local elections sakistama unveiling new
plans for the NHS alongside some more
familiar warnings about its future I
don't think the NHS supplies five more
years of Tory government
people say oh well we've heard this
before the labor party is always saying
it's time to save the NHS
but I say
look squarely in the eyes of the people
who work in the NHS who serve the NHS
and ask them Center Stage ambitious new
targets and a new focus on prevention
early diagnosis and Technology what was
missing though how much it will all cost
how do you expect the public to trust
you with the public finances if you're
not prepared to say quite
straightforwardly these are our plans
this is how much they will cost and this
is how we will pay for them this
challenge you put to me that we've not
said where the money is coming from is
just wrong actually are we going to have
the biggest increase in training for the
NHS that it's ever had in its history
yes are we going to pay for that by
abolishing the non-dom tax status yes so
what we've been careful to do is to say
where we're making changes what the
change will be and how we will pay for
it Labor's list of all the things that
they would do to improve the NHS is a
very long one there is no shortage of
ideas but about patience do they believe
that the party can deliver on all of
these promises kirst Armor's track
record of making pledges and then
reneging on them is something he needs
to address I think I don't think it's in
good hands under anybody because I
honestly don't think they know what's
going on at the sharp end some people
saying you need more money but the point
is do we have enough people who actually
want to work in the health system you
know that's the thing some reservations
as well from a leading Health Think Tank
the commitments around
a realistic 10-year plan to improve but
kids also committed to restoring NHS
waiting time standards within five years
those standards haven't been met since
2015 and this isn't just a backlog
caused by the pandemic this is a
long-term challenge around the
performance of the NHS but I do think
five years whilst it's right to be
ambitious it's probably not deliverable
thank you today was Labor trying to
convince voters it is ready for
government part of a journey they hope
will end at Downing Street this Bates
Sky News Essex
is with me so some big promises there
but the data would suggest that labor
has quite a mountain to climb quite
apart from how to pay for all of this
what kirstama has done is looked at the
key areas that concern patience and
health workers and us as the public and
when we've been reporting on the winter
crisis in the NHS what really worries us
we worry about ambulance times we worry
about the elective waitingness we worry
about not being able to see RGB so these
are the areas he says he wants to tackle
he wants to reform the NHS but you're
right he doesn't answer the question
about money and budget what he does say
is we'll make that money available we'll
show you our spending plans closer to
the election but then and the caveat is
we're not going to spend the sort of
money that labor governments have spent
on the NHS in the past it's also about
efficient efficiencies and investing in
technology but all of that investment
needs money let's look at some of the
the concerns patients have had let's
look at any waiting times he's made this
a big pleasure look in 2010 it was the
percentage was about three percent and
then it's grown all the way through year
after year after year except that dip
there and we know why that was in
January 2020 when patients weren't going
to hospital because of the pandemic and
even then the peak above 30 percent in
2023 and it's only just climbing down
even now we're still seeing 25.4 of
patients who are waiting more than four
hours in a e and he says that's
unacceptable and he wants to make that
one of his key priorities how is he
going to do it let's look at the sort of
money that previous labor
administrations have spent you see in
the early days when they came to power
1997 they swept to power on the back of
making the NHS one of their key
priorities during their election
campaign Manifesto they spent money on
it all the way through to
2009 10 and then the Coalition and look
at the sharp four and the percentage of
money that was being spent on the NHS by
the coalition government and then by the
conservatives and then 2010 again it's a
negative spend because
um no 2020 a negative spend because of
the the pandemic and now the plan spend
on the NHS for 2024 is still much lower
than any of those labor years so he's
got some very difficult questions to
answer he talks about efficiencies but
he still will need to show us how he's
going to spend the money and how much
money he's going to plow into the NHS to
realize his ambitious plans Ashish thank
you
now the man accused of killing four
students in the U.S state of Idaho last
year appeared in court today and refused
to enter a plea the judge pled not
guilty on his behalf Brian coburger is
accused of the murders as our U.S
correspondent James Matthews reports
Brian korberger is the man accused of
the student killings that shocked
America he faces murder charges on
multiple codes
yes yes yes
he answered four times yes to
acknowledge the four murders he's
charged with a prosecuting attorney but
the judge had to plead not guilty on his
behalf after coburger declined to plead
guilty or otherwise
he is accused of entering this house at
King Road and Moscow Idaho and in the
middle of the night carrying out
quadruple murder
the victims were three female flatmates
and a partner staying the night Ethan
Chapin and Zana kernodle were stabbed to
death in one bedroom
lifelong friends Kelly gonzalves and
Madison Morgan were killed in another
of two students left unharmed in the
house one told detectors she stood
Frozen as a man dressed in black wearing
a mask and with bushy eyebrows walked
past her
police would take six weeks to arrest
Brian corberger a criminal justice
student at Washington State University
this was him a few weeks before the
murder a police officer stopped him for
a traffic offense in his white Hyundai
a month after the killings coburger was
stopped again twice for traffic offenses
with his father on a road trip home to
Pennsylvania
hello how you doing how y'all doing
today police found out he changed the
registration plates and the car like his
was seen near the site of the murderers
six weeks after the murderous police
made their move this was their raid on
his West Coast apartment goldberger was
arrested in Pennsylvania and flown back
to face the case against him it includes
a DNA match between a knife pouch left
at the murder scene and rubbish from
Burns at his family home
in Idaho it's case evidence that leaves
him looking at the possibility of the
death penalty by firing squad James
Matthews Sky News Washington
Russian officials have accused a
Ukrainian sabotage group of crossing the
border and launching an attack in the
region of Belgard these images which
haven't been independently verified were
shown on Russian television local
officials claim eight people were
injured in artillery far well Kiev has
denied any link to the fighting and
blamed it on a Revolt by disgruntled
Russians
searching for an 18 year old man who's
seen in videos posted on social media
entering a home apparently without
permission police say they've identified
the person and believe he may have
breached a community protection order
which was issued last May in response to
videos previously posted online
Junior doctors in England have announced
another 72-hour strike next month
members of the British Medical
Association will walk out from the 14th
to the 17th of June describing the five
percent pay rise they've been offered as
poultry the government says the
announcement is both surprising and
deeply disappointing
he is one of the bravest people you
could imagine a bystander who helped
take down a terrorist using a narwhal
Tusk Tara Frost's experience of the
aftermath of the attack on fishmongers
Hall in London was very similar to that
of other atrocities with a lack of
professional help a report published
today highlighted that lack of support
revealing a third of young people caught
up in the Manchester Arena attack who
needed Mental Health Care didn't get it
Sky's Catherine of a tootsie reports
foreign
deadly attack that changed lives in an
instant
on the night they survived the
Manchester Arena attack these young
women were young girls this Memorial in
Manchester remembers the 22 that died in
an atrocity that traumatized hundreds I
kept having flashbacks and not being
able to do things because of that not
wanting to go out and not listen to
music and just like a whole kind of life
just kind of switched up a bit the
thought of being a necessian you know
all the noises like the sirens the loud
bangs that you hear the crowds of people
like that really really scared me they
all needed mental health support but had
different experiences of getting it
especially through NHS Services known as
cams I was able to get into cams after a
really rough road with the GP and they
basically said like well it'll take you
two years to get into cams and it would
actually be easier to treat you if you
were anorexic or suicidal and so you
know basically get on with it and she
basically asked us to leave
today a new report has found a third of
young people who needed mental health
care after the attack simply didn't get
it many people in the research said that
their parents paid for them to get
support in the end because they were
waiting far too long on NHS waiting
lists so that's not fair either this was
an attack against the state it should be
the state that steps up and supports
them the Prince of Wales who's met with
young survivors of the attack says
today's report makes it clear their
stories must be heard but even adults
Heroes have struggled to find help
in 2019 in London Darren Frost fought
off a terrorist with an animal tusk
I've never been the same again and
I don't know if I ever will but I'm
trying to look at the positives it has
changed me it made me struggle with
memory I've learned that this is an
effective trauma and I get confused
quite easily by things that are used to
find quite simple
the thing with terror is it is horrific
when it happens but it is actually quite
uncommon and very rare
the resource required to look after this
group of people is relatively small
compared to the population
the government told Sky News it knows
there is more to do and is expected to
make changes to give better support to
survivors of Terror Katrina Sky News
Manchester
the company behind Facebook faced a
record fine today 1.2 billion euros for
transferring the data of its users to
the United States it said the penalty
imposed by an e regulator was
unjustified but it's raised again the
question of how much data the Giant and
others hold on all of us as our Science
and Technology editor Tom Clarke reports
meta is facing the largest data
protection fine ever issued under EU law
gdpr is five years old this week and
this will give privacy campaigners
something to celebrate though Brussels
knows meta will appeal we want to bring
back legal certainty Clarity with this
decision it's clear I think also
commissioner Randall said this before
that we expect it would also be
challenged at some point but the bottom
line is we are working on the basis of
the safegues that the courts demanded an
appeal should buy meta time to come up
with a solution something to persuade
the EU its citizens data is protected
from snooping by the U.S security
agencies for example
a new data sharing agreement expected
this summer should help but that isn't
expected to solve a very thorny issue
for Facebook which is what to do with
about a decades worth of EU users data
stored on servers in the US
does it delete the lot can it even do
that
it's a logistical challenge that could
take years I'm not sure of the degree to
which meta would know that that bucket
of data is purely the data of EU users
and that bucket of data is purely the
data of Australian users or us users and
I think it's a very very big task for
them to try and Carry Out meta says the
decision sets a dangerous precedent for
other companies what's likely is they're
ensuing legal Wrangler over data will
make an already complicated situation
more so take companies operating in the
UK not affected by this EU decision but
using very similar gdpr laws
smaller firms risk falling foul of the
rules while big companies like meta can
afford the lawyers to stay ahead of The
Regulators Tom Clark Sky News
is one of the world's top footballers
impressing in the colors of Real Madrid
and Brazil he is also the victim of a
hate crime according to his Club after
they reported racial abuse he'd suffered
to prosecutors he said a championship
which had once belonged to Giant
slightly in our Messi now belonged to
racists our Europe correspondent Adam
Parsons reports doing in Spanish
football this is all too familiar a
black player racially abused not by one
person but by a whole section of the
crowd monkey They shout this happened at
Valencia the target Real Madrid's
Brazilian attacker vinicius Jr
afterwards he released a statement
it wasn't the first time nor the second
nor the third racism is normal in La
Liga the competition thinks it's normal
the Federation does too and the
opponents encourage it I'm so sorry the
championship that once belonged to
Ronaldinho Ronaldo Cristiano and Messi
today belongs to racists
his coach a toughened veteran of
European football seemed shocked
what happened today has happened many
times but it can't happen anymore this
is unacceptable the Spanish league has a
problem and it's not vinicius Spanish
football has a chronic problem with
racism look at this Barcelona's Danny
Alves reacting calmly after a banana is
thrown at him we
um know of 10 incidents that have been
directed at benicius this season
everything from the monkey chants that
are quite familiar to an effigy of him
hung from a bridge by Atletico Madrid
France Brazil's president Furious
I think it's important that FIFA the
Spanish league and the leagues of other
countries take the strongest actions
possible because we can't allow Fascism
and racism to become part of life at a
soccer stadium and this won't go away
Real Madrid demanding an inquiry saying
Real Madrid believes that such attacks
also constitute a hate crime and has
therefore filed the corresponding Report
with the Attorney General's office
specifically with the prosecutor's
office against crimes of hatred and
discrimination the FIFA president said
he's supportive vinicius he said the
game should have been suspended but the
Spanish league president seemed
unperturbed claiming vinicius should be
better informed before criticizing the
league
Felicia's Junior ended the game getting
a very harsh red card abused angry and
emotional or Spanish football finally
confront its demons
Adam Parsons Sky News
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at bro's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this story on the front page
of the eye the headline number 10 leaves
bravman waiting on her future but
tonight we're joined by the political
editors of the guardian and the son of
akura and Harry Cole back in just a
moment
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
use in just a moment the Press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
first though a reminder of our top
stories the Home Secretary has insisted
nothing untoward happened following
reports that she asked civil servants to
arrange a private speed awareness course
for her
[Music]
police investigating The Disappearance
of Madeleine McCann are preparing to
search a Reservoir in Portugal not far
from where she went missing
and the labor leader secure starmer has
set out his plans for the NHS
saying it wouldn't survive another five
years under the Tories
[Music]
foreign
a first look at what is on the front
pages as they arrive time them to see
what's making the headlines with the
political editors of the guardian and
the Sun papakura and Harry Cole they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight welcome to both of you so to
the eye first of all it says Rishi sunak
has yet to make a decision over whether
to launch a formal ethics inquiry over
the Home Secretary swella bravman's
handling of her speeding offense last
year the guardian carries the findings
of an investigation which heard that
thousands of hospital staff have
reported that they've been sexually
abused while at work the Metro has the
renewed search for Madeleine McCann at a
Portuguese Reservoir near to where she
went missing back in 2007 the sun calls
the situation the riddle of the lake
similarly here is the mirror the
headline Maddie cops search Lake
the guardian the financial times rather
reports on Facebook's parent company
meta being fined more than a billion
pounds by the eu's Privacy regulator
over how it handled users data and the
times leading on government plans to cut
NHS waiting lists by encouraging
patients to use the NHS app to choose
treatment in private hospitals well
quick reminder don't forget to scan that
QR code that you'll see on screen during
the program and you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's newspapers
while you watch us before we listen and
get more from Pippa and Harry let us
bring you some breaking news we're just
getting Sky News understands that
Dominic Robb will stand down as an MP at
the next election he of course MP4 Isha
and Walton since 2010 he had recently
held the post of Deputy Prime Minister
and Justice secretary forced to stand
down over bullying allegations which he
disputed but previously he had been
brexit secretary and then foreign
secretary under which he oversaw and was
criticized for the pull-out from
Afghanistan so our understanding is that
Mr Rob will not stand as an MP at the
next general election well let's head to
Our Guest then and get more on that
um Harry I don't suppose this comes as
too much of a surprise for people
foreign
no I don't think so look at the um look
at the local lib Dems in his patch it
was a tight seat anyway he only just
scraped back a couple of times in the
last few many elections we've had of
late
um obviously incredibly disillusioned uh
figure from Deputy Prime Minister to
back bencher to now XM soon to be XMP
whenever the election comes I think um
it was no surprise
um to people who who've seen Dominic
Robb of late spoken in the last month he
does feel very very poorly treated I
think
um by not only not necessarily the Prime
Minister but um certainly
um left-wing activists trade unions like
the FDA who did you know did coordinate
a lot of complaints that turned out not
to have been upheld that what he does
feel there was a bit of a a Witch Hunt
against him one complaint was upheld
which was a very senior official who had
been caught red-handed trying to
undermine brexit negotiations
um and yeah it was slightly more
complicated than the sort of image of a
workplace bully that was allowed to sort
of propagate for for months and months
so no surprise what you see him throw in
the towel and um I suspect you'll um
yeah didn't fancy another five years on
the back benches a paper a lot of
shaking of head there um you explain
your position
well I agree with Harry that the lib
Dems were snapping at Dominic Rob's
heels he had a majority of just over 2
000 in 2019 compared to a majority of 23
000 two years before that so he looks
set to lose the election he also in his
letter to his constituency chairman
cites and pressure of his job over many
years on his young family he's got two
sons I think are just eight and ten as a
consideration many politicians share but
I'm afraid his characterization of the
Dominic Dominic Rob bullying though I
think is uh slightly should we say
one-sided to say it was too um just that
two uh complaints were upheld is not the
case one of those complaints was was
several and but more than several a
number of civil servants
um Junior ones and Senior ones at the
ministry of Justice it was a it wasn't
the group complaint which wasn't upheld
it was it was the individual ones and I
think Adam Tolley because he was the the
um KC that was carrying out the
investigation uh called for about
arranged by Rishi sinach
um into those allegations over for
several months because he came to the
conclusion that
he wanted to protect the anonymity of
the civil servants because obviously
they don't have a public voice and
indeed the witnesses he left out a lot
of detail of the report but we reported
a lot of these stories and some of the
detail was incredibly harrowing about
how he treated civil servants and how he
made them feel including in one case
pushing somebody to the brink of suicide
which is a very serious allegation and
another of the complaints which wasn't
upheld from his time back in dexu uh
when he was briefly brexit secretary was
only not uh basically Holly didn't come
to judgment either way because he said
it was so uh long ago so I think to say
that he's been hard done by and it was
some civil service
is very much what dominic Robb and his
supporters would like you to say I think
yeah
he feels hard but I said he feels hard
done by anyone who's spoken to him said
this is how how he feels this is him he
feels badly treated yeah okay and I
think some in that group complex claimed
had actually accepted that they hadn't
actually had much interaction with him
so you know that fed it to him
gotcha anyway he is one as we know of a
number of resignations from the sunat
government
um he'll be hoping to hold on to swella
bravman one imagines
um so the guardian if we kick off with
that and might as well stay with you
pepper on this if you don't mind
um the most senior civil servant in the
home office was made aware of
allegations that swella bravman wanted
to help in dealing with a speeding fine
so explain the significance of that then
right so I mean it's really interesting
because uh this story obviously broke on
Saturday afternoon and the expectation I
think when people came back to
Westminster today was and of course
Richard was flying back from Japan was
that he would uh consult with his ethics
advisor
um Laurie Magnus and that he would
probably ask him to investigate this
these claims
um and of course that hasn't that hasn't
happened today
um I think you know Carlson back to
dominate Robb which is like took a
couple of days there as well number 10
suggest that he wants to see once for
the due process he wants to be seen to
be doing
um things the right way so he's
obviously taking time to find out
himself what the facts were before he
asks Laurie Magnus to to investigate if
indeed he does do that
um uh so this story in the guardian is
is a suggestion that the civil servant
who was
um who was asked by Sola bravman to
arrange um according to the claims to
arrange
um uh private a bespoke driving
awareness course um was understood that
it was that it was potentially a breach
of the code that certainly shouldn't be
something that they should be asked to
do and reported that up to
um to Matthew rycroft as the permanent
secretary the most senior official in
the department and what it does I think
is raise the question about whether
other senior officials
um or indeed other other senior
politicians knew about these allegations
which of course all happened back in
September even though they only just
came out now so it's question marks
about who knew what and when
um what I guess while we wait to see
what Richardson decides to do in terms
of an Ethics investigation into the
allegations yes and that idea of waiting
again makes the front page of the eye
Harry says no I know Jacob we smog was
suggesting that
um you know celebrities can have private
um speeding hearings or um you know the
lesson rather than taking the three
points if she'd asked anybody else would
it have been all right for her to ask or
was it just plain wrong on every level
no that's what the number of this comes
down to she's bringing up a lawyer and
said can I can you organize me a private
um a private meeting um Mr loophole one
of the one of the lawyers one of the
sort of driving lawyers has come out in
public he said he's organized loads of
VIP uh one-on-one meetings there's no
there's a question of whether it's a bad
look that the the homes actually didn't
want to sort of mingle with the public
so to speak but then you know her
Defenders are saying we've got to take
into security concerns so when she did
raise in the office and no one's dying
that she did raise it in the office and
say look how could I do this do I kind
of is there a chance I can do this
one-on-one
um it looks like the Civil Service it
went into the Civil Service machine I
think it reached all as far as the
cabinet office before it came back and
said actually no this isn't really
something the Civil Service can help you
with now the question of the nub of this
issue is is did her asking her private
office for advice
constitute a breach of the ministerial
code now that's what I think the delay
in in the ethics advisor and the prime
minister is is coming down to is is that
a breach that is worthy of an
investigation if it is a breach is it
was he just you know sort of looking at
her different options ultimately she
didn't she didn't do this so I suspect
it feels like the longer this goes on it
felt a change in mood tonight that
actually it feels like perhaps we should
see that we saw him saw him in the
Commons uh sweater braveman and kind of
supportively on the back when he arrived
in the Commons is he actually thinking
but perhaps this has been a little bit
overblown he wants to see the paper
trail he wants to know if things were
done in the right way and actually maybe
there won't be the investigation that
that the opposition are clamoring for
and actually you know because nothing
nothing actually came of it
um whether this really is a breach so I
suspect we'll know very early tomorrow
morning yes I've done nothing on tour
doesn't mean I didn't try to do
something Untold I suppose so her
critics were done
toward though his thing is the question
I think you know is it award to say
actually is there a way as the Home
Secretary with my security detail that I
can go to a meeting one-on-one it's it's
whether it's whether you know no one's
suggesting that she tried to avoid being
paying the fine or doing the course you
know if she'd be trying to get out the
course and pay the fine obviously that's
untoward but I haven't seen any evidence
yet of anyone actually suggesting that
she tried to avoid some form of
punishment which is either the course or
the points
go for it pepper I honestly I can see
you're itching no good yeah it's
obviously not um I was absolutely right
it's not suggesting that she was trying
to avoid it but the point is the
ministerial code is quite clear about
either either a parent or actual
conflicts um and that and that ministers
need to take need to keep their public
duties apart from their private lives so
that means the ministers can't for
example ask their civil servants to
arrange their Tesco shopping to be
delivered or their kids to be picked up
from school or indeed to sort out um
Arrangement arrangea uh speeding
awareness course and and I think what it
comes down to is did she ask them for
advice or did she direct them as some of
the claims suggest did she direct them
to actually arrange that uh arrange that
course and I think I suspect that's what
will come down to ultimately but
regardless it does feel like on the on
the Lesser end the lower end if you like
of potential breaches and under the new
rules it's not just okay piece of sort
of a binary case of either administrator
and guilty and they're sacked or they're
not found guilty and they stay in post
there's a range of sanctions available
to the Prime Minister including things
like public apology or docking a bit of
the ministry or salary and it feels
likely that if this investigation goes
forwards and if and there's lots of this
here I understand that
um that she's found to breach the code
that we wouldn't necessarily even in
that case expect her to go yes indeed
well actually the eye in its a few
paragraphs on it it's front page says
that bravman is picking fights and
looking for an excuse to get sacked as
new party divisions break into the open
the kind of suggestion was that that's
what happened last time she resigned
Harry
well that was a a crazy time for
everyone which if anyone wants to know
exactly what happened there they should
buy my book I've got to get a plug in
there
is clearly a controversial figure you
know but I don't think actually reality
if you see if you think why Richardson
bought it back just 10 days after she
was sacked by Liz truss she was her
coming over to Richie sunac and and
pulling out the race and saying it's got
to be rishy basically it's killed Boris
Johnson's hopes of come back last
October stone dead so you know she is a
powerful figure on the right she is a
leadership Contender she was almost
certainly going to be one of the if
notorious lose the election one of the
major candidates for the to be the
leader of the opposition so you know
politically it's a headache for sudak as
well she may be itching for a fight but
I'm not saying she's unsackable and if I
do say that she'll probably get fired
tomorrow but you know you've got to look
at where sunak is he is not in a great
position at the moment yes he's got the
sort of party rump of MPS and ministers
behind him but the right wing of the
party are cross they are agitating they
want more Vision they want tax cuts they
want something done about migration all
building up to Thursday when there's
this great Crescendo of the the
government's failure on immigration and
all the promises laid bare before
everyone's eyes Rishi sunak isn't going
to want to take that by himself he's
going to want to braveman there is a bit
of a human shield to keep the right wing
of his party happy so it's much stronger
position than people on Twitter would
would have you believe well I mean you
say a failure of government policy but
are we actually being able to
send our pigs to the abattoir because we
brought an abattoir workers and actually
staff our Care Homes because they
brought in Care Home workers so that's
what people will be analyzing on
Thursday when they see the migration
workers and the sort of skilled workers
who've come in on that I'm just going to
revert to the Daily Telegraph paper
um on the front page they've got the Rob
story there um they say the Daily
Telegraph has seen an exchange of
letters between the former deputy prime
minister and the chairman of his local
conservative Association explaining his
decision Mr Robb wrote the letter dated
last Friday I have become increasingly
concerned over the last few years about
the pressure the job has placed on my
young family his sons Peter and Joshua
as you said age 10 and 8 respectively
are points you've already made but the
telegraph has that story on its front
page anyway lots more still to come the
next part of our program including
secure starma outlining Labor's plans
for the NHS do they stack up more on
that in just a moment
[Music]
independent United Kingdom
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
foreign these stories have been driven
by politics by politicians the people in
power you must stay at home and it's my
job to figure out how these decisions
made by politicians impact all of us in
our everyday lives this is the worst
thing I've ever been through in my life
people turn up here with their child's
stuff in a black sack and just say I
don't want to and that is what it is
it's first class profiter is this an
example of the welfare state failing we
take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world these are stories
that affect us all
billions of children are now having to
catch up some stories have changed all
of our Lives because like the residents
the staff are being infected politicians
they make decisions all of the time and
it's our job to hold them to account I
wonder if you will take this opportunity
to apologize to those families but in
the end the real power doesn't actually
lie with the politicians
the real power lies with the people
I'm Nick Martin I'm the people and
politics correspondent at Sky News
[Music]
[Applause]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
Greg Milan Sky News Manchester
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Cole from the guardian and the sun
welcome back to both of you
um so big day in terms of NHS and labor
Pippa my NHS reforms will cut the
biggest Killers within a decade he's
talking about heart disease cancer
suicide as well but some big pledges I
don't know what money he's talking about
and some very familiar looking targets
which were very blairite I thought
listening to them
for the one just play right they were
they're Tory targets I mean there's a
series of five targets about ranging
from things like um any waiting times to
ambulance weights to cancer referrals
which have been proposed by the
government
um and which Libra has said that they
would deliver in the first five years of
the labor government and prompting some
sort of skepticism as to whether they're
actually deliverable deliverable but I
think that skepticism really just goes
so goes far to show
um what sort of lack of faith people
have in in government running the NHS at
the moment given it's um it's really uh
you know it's in many cases it's on its
knees I can caveat that with the fact
that hospitals GPS and and other NHS
providers offer an incredible service
despite the pressures that they face on
um on Workforce and and other and other
issues but yes this is one of cure
starma's uh five missions which he is
setting out we've already had let me get
this right crime the economy and
education and I think we've got
um the climates still to come health is
obviously a big one NHS is often at the
top of the list of Buddha's concerns
coming up to an election and this is not
a sort of a policy this is not their
policy proposals
um in their entirety on the NHS this is
supposed to be sort of like the work
underpinning what will then be set out
at the Autumn conference then ahead of
an election in a Manifesto next year but
what kirstema was unable to do today in
any of the broadcast interviews that he
did this morning and indeed in the
questions after this event that you've
you're picturing there was to to set out
explicitly how some of these changes
would be funded I think the closest we
got to it was him acknowledging in an
interview beforehand that in signaling
that the word that labor government
would put more funding into the NHS in
England they've talked a lot about
wanting to reform it but they have
acknowledged and he said
um that yes he put his uh his uh he was
asked about where he put his money where
his mouth is on this and he said yes
money is part of the answer and the NHS
is always funded better funded under
labor so that was a step forward from
where we got to build have been before
and that he's at least saying he's
acknowledging that it will require some
cash what he's not yet doing is setting
out in its entirety where that money
would come from there's a few specific
examples like you know more doctors and
nurses paid for by
um paid for by scrapping the non-dom tax
and so on but um I think there'll be an
expectation from the electorate that he
he does set out more detail they say
they're going to do that let's see but
it's so key to vote of trust in whether
government's future governments um are
likely to be able to deliver
um on on some of the policies like we
saw today yeah okay um very interesting
uh quick 30 seconds Financial Times
talking about meta we finally found out
what gdpr does apart from make us go
except dog cookies endlessly at Harry
foreign
yeah I'm pretty hefty whacking great
find there which I think
um you know I'm one of the people that
gives the uh EU its fair amount of stick
over the years but you know this is
clearly something globally that um lots
of people have uh uh you know are
incredibly concerned about our Online
safety bill in the UK is you know
somewhere bouncing around I think in the
House of Commons has the Lords at the
moment clampdowns on sort of the the
tech Giants are coming and this is where
the EU can use its heft you know that
matter probably the most famous one of
the most famous and biggest companies in
the world has hit a wall here I suspect
there'll be loads of legal wranglings
around it but it's certainly a good sign
of a show of intention that you know
these companies cannot be bigger than
countries and bigger than bigger than
you know governments and need to be
brought to Hill from time to time so
yeah good on them okay Harry Pippa thank
you both very much indeed obviously lots
of coverage to of Madeleine McCann to
quite that in the 11 o'clock when you're
back right now let's check out the
weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the country remaining under the
influence of high pressure through the
rest of the week and across the Spring
Bank holiday weekend this will bring
quiet conditions with spells of warm
sunshine for many any remaining Cloud
over Southern and Southeastern England
will clear to give a bright or sunny
start for the bulk of the country Cloud
will increase over Scotland and Northern
Ireland some patchy light rain will
drizzle around it will be a dry morning
though elsewhere with sunny spells fair
with a cloud bubbling up may give an
isolated chart for Wales and for Central
England cooler than yesterday
temperatures widely reaching the late
teens or a high of 70 degrees Fahrenheit
to fly the weather sponsored by Qatar
Airways
[Music]
thank you